Peggy 18
hi everyone I'm ed boon from death row
Studios here to debut a Mortal Kombat X
fighter we know fans have been keeping
an eye out for Kano in MKX K knows a bit
older but with all his cybernetic
upgrades
he's deadlier than ever and like all
characters Kano has three variations
that will enhance combat tactics and
bring a variety of different moves today
we'll match him up against one of our
new combatants Devorah we take the fight
to the jungle ancient ruins overgrown
with wilderness that was once home to a
now forgotten out world race kini hello
my lovely you repulse us hideous one
right in the cut rope variation cantle
pounds on a cybernetic art to power up
his attacks and his enhanced night
fighting skills allow for a number of
new combo
the cybernetic variation gives Kano an
arsenal of AI laser and grenade attacks
allowing him to strike them long range
and defend against aerial attack and
last but not least the commando
variation enhances knose grappling
skills and allows them to counter both
high and low attackers a lethal
combination that both rounds opponents
while overwhelming them at close range
finish que no wings